foreign
it's much bigger than you know downtown
El Paso it's much bigger than the rescue
mission it's much bigger than Texas it's
it's a nationwide problem
my name is Nicole roulet I'm the
director of marketing here at the rescue
mission of El Paso and being in a border
City we've always had you know a migrant
Presence at our shelters but since
September of last year that presence has
significantly grown
the Deering Gap is a 60 mile stretch of
jungle that a lot of migrants have to
pass through especially coming from
Venezuela which is a big majority of who
we have here
so in that jungle there's no roads
um there's wild animals poisonous plants
a lot can go wrong in there and it's
mostly run by Cartel who traffic the
people through I heard of a gentleman
here who went into that jungle with 900
people and came out with 400 on the
other side so that jungle is essentially
just a big graveyard but it's part of
passing through on foot you know there
should be a process that is you know
attainable for everybody but that's the
that's the problem is that for a lot of
people there's so many obstacles and the
whole process is so complicated and
drawn out that it creates this sense of
desperation this sense of urgency of you
know like am I am I going to make it
through am I going to be able to stay
um am I going to you know grow roots
here am I going to be able to do that or
am I going to be uprooted and sent right
back to where I started with nothing
so much that people have sacrificed to
come here they've left everything they
know behind they've sold everything they
have they've sacrificed months
sacrificed limbs sometimes lives
sometimes people will make it here
there's a lot of people who were trying
to get here who didn't make it and so
there's there's a lot of sacrifice that
comes with coming and you know when they
travel through there's a lot of cartels
a lot of Mafia that they encounter that
take advantage of them who don't see
them as people but see them as products
to be moved and profit from also they
see the women as products to be sold
it's not it's not an easy decision to
make it's not an easy journey to get
here and it's not a sense of entitlement
that I see from most of the family
staying here it's a sense of desperation
I think it's a huge problem in this
whole factor of things because for
cartels they're kind of incentivized to
get these people through because that's
a profit for them you know they can make
money off of that but again they don't
see them as people they see them as
products and so there's many people who
in the middle of their Journey even
though they've paid at the beginning in
the middle they'll up the price and if
you can't pay that price you get killed
or someone gets ransomed
um I personally have seen a video
um from a migrant woman here who she was
coming with her uncle and her cousin
and that's what happened to them in the
middle of their Journey they upped the
price
um they were only able to pay her way
through and so she showed me a video on
her phone that they had her sent to
their family of her uncle and her cousin
they're begging for their lives and
they're being beaten with machetes it
was just so horrific but that's
that's normal for migrants passing
through that's not an unusual story for
something like that to happen there's a
lot of kids who have seen their parents
either killed or raped in front of them
too and so there's a huge psychological
factor into it too that these migrants
are very traumatized and have incredible
trust issues so for them to get into a
white van to come to a shelter takes a
lot of trust for them and they're that's
how desperate they are is that they have
to nitpick every decision they make
they're very unsure and very vulnerable
because of what they've been through
um usually especially the kids when they
come you can see it in their eyes like
that they've seen things that no kids
should ever have to see
it really is a humanitarian crisis I was
raised to believe in school and taught
to believe in school that you know our
country is one of the greatest countries
and we are built on immigrants some of
our best entrepreneurs have been
immigrants That We're a nation of
migrants I was taught that the Statue of
Liberty is the mother of migrants and I
was taught her inscription of give us
your hungry and you're poor and your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
and you know
ideally I think in a perfect world that
is exactly who we are but realistically
when you live in a border City and you
see the reality behind those things
um it's disheartening and it shows that
you know the the principles or the the
reputation that we've had in the past
isn't isn't coming true today